but right now we have nikkor gone from
ascension thanks for joining us I love
doing this once or twice a year oh it's
so great to have you so you partner with
ascension partners with the Chess Club
for your move job second year the
program we had our second annual
fundraiser on May 31st and we raised
over $110,000 which doubled last year's
total our first year and we're now with
the Chess Club able to expand the
program into more understood underserved
schools and also begin to embed the
program into curricula what you think is
exciting and I think the goal for this
coming year is to expand it outside of
st. Louis into some additional markets
that's fabulous you said over $100,000
what happened at a fundraiser so we had
some so this year we thanks to the
generosity of Fabiano and Eric Hansen
and Danny wrench from chess comm we did
some blood blitz I'm moles there and we
actually auctioned off the opportunity
for people to play blitz against some of
the greatest GM's in the world including
myself and I got destroyed I actually
got checkmated twice they forgot that
maybe once but okay I played Bobby and
he he would he did not take it easy on
me but it was it was really
extraordinary me we had we had people
auctioning off the opportunity to play
blitz and Saima with some of the
greatest GM's on the planet and then at
the end we actually had Fabi take on
three GM's at a national manse national
master in a you know Saima lits and he
didn't fare as well as it's a tough
competition but it was a lot of fun and
I think the people enjoyed watching
these GM's play blitz which is pretty
incredible
that's a cool concept the Blitz imal is
basically really crazy that doesn't
happen too often so basically the the
player has to play like four or five the
grandmaster has to play four or five
people at once and we know all the games
within five minutes yeah there were five
minutes animals which are tough and in
the first two rounds it was against kind
of average people and and they had no
problem dispatching us but then and in
the last round file we had to play a
bunch of other GM's and world class GM's
including Eric and others and and that
was tough but for the average person
that was there seeing it for the first
time the the amount of skill that goes
into playing a blitz imal I think was
eye-opening in and through that cyma we
raised an additional $15,000 just by
people auction
off the right to play against some of
these players and it was a nice little
wrinkle and next year we hope to do some
more of that and and build upon our
total that's amazing you know so many
listeners here in the show asked how can
I get involved this show is free the
YouTube channel videos are for free and
so they could actually buy a ticket to
this fundraiser yeah
right and then see some of these things
in person yeah the fundraiser ticket
class the tickets themselves for
individual only twenty five dollars so
we wanted to you know we obviously had a
lot of corporate partners and that
that's where I'm pretty good at raising
money from our corporate partners so we
had those donations and we raised so
much that we figured we could drop the
price for the average person that wanted
to come in and see some of the best GM's
on the planet watch the Blitz animals or
participate and so next year I think
we'll do the same thing we really want
to we had over 300 people at the event
and it's just it's taken on life of its
own I think it's now become something
that people look forward to and like I
said our goal is to expand into a few
other markets were looking at Nashville
Tennessee in Birmingham Alabama at a few
others and it's some of the markets
where ascensions at and I could tell you
our associates also donated a lot to the
program starting with our CEO on down
and I think are the essential community
loves the intersection of chess and
learning we think that it's something
that we could take to other markets
that's so huge well and speaking of
looking forward to I know that you're a
chess player yourself and of course you
must look forward to this the Ziegfeld
Cup what do you think it's gonna happen
this year well I was I was fixated on
yesterday's game between mdl Magnus I
was I was amazed to see MDL win that
game on black especially when he's down
a little bit early on and I'm a big
Fabiano fan he's been so generous to our
program so I'm rooting for him I know
he's in second and I think he has a good
game going on today but you know I'm
curious to see how Magnus rebounds that
was a I don't know how many times he's
lost I'm white after having a I don't
know if a winning position but certainly
he had something of an advantage he was
winning at some point yeah it was very
complicated and nvl played it seemed
like to my untrained eye perfect chess
from there on out and so I'm curious to
see how Magnus rebounds and I'm really
looking forward to the blitz next week
and see how Gary does Kasparov coming
out of retirement and you know going
into the deep end of the pool at some of
the blessed the best blitz players on
the planet so somebody wants to donate
to this program rather than just coming
out to the fundraiser because that's a
whole year
how else can they do just go to
Ascension org backslash your move chess
and we fundraise you around or they can
just go to the Chess Club website or
they could Google me and send me an
email Nick Oregon however they want but
we we were really delighted at the
number of not only that we double the
size of the donations but we doubled the
number of people who contributed in
fundraising that's what we wanted to
expand the fundraising days exactly no
amount too small but especially no
amount too big special thanks ADA
Maurice who helped us two years ago kick
off this program and this year Danny
wrench did a great job of broadcasting
this imal which is not easy to do to try
to make very complicated positions
understandable for the layperson oh yes
and I heard Danny's gonna be in town
we're actually going to be playing a
blitz match out on the O the patio chess
with the world chess Hall of Fame so
some exercise all right I'll try yeah
you know Blackie doesn't know how to
play again okay teams candy my brother's
not gonna talk to me anymore I can't say
that on TV
I gotta come out and watch that I mean
you got to take Danny down well thank
you so much for all your support and for
your passion for chess is great to have
people behind the chess club and our
partners also showing how much they love
the game and we are gonna be back with
more from round five of the seen field
cup after just a few minutes thanks Nick